fausse alerte en belgique le journaliste
hospitalisé hier soir juste après son
retour de turquie ne présente pas les
symptômes de la grippe aviaire annonce
faite cet après midi par les autorités
médicales belge après bien sûr les
examens nécessaires en france si une
telle situation se présentait qu'est-il
prévu dans les hôpitaux exemple au chu
de nancy
jennifer alberte des masques des bottes
et des blues de protection le chu de
nancy est prêt en cas de suspicion de
grippe aviaire une protection maximale
est évidente des salles d'examen
spéciales sont même prévues de passion
et tout de suite
isolé vers une filière spécifique et il
est équipé de protections tout comme le
soignant et puis après on a précédé la
fuite yvan qui consiste à faire un
prélèvement un prélèvement à partir d'un
kit naso pharyngé qui est envoyé dans un
laboratoire référent national qui en a
lyon il y en a donc à paris en attendant
48 heures un délai dans une confirmation
de cette suspension en cas de
confirmation le patient serait alors
orienté vers un autre établissement de
nancy dans un service de maladies
infectieuses et tropicales
les procédures sont donc parfaitement au
point les équipes soignantes ont
d'ailleurs eu l'occasion de les tester
cette seconde
venons en turquie et toute la procédure
qui est réalisée l'été indiqué mais en
cas de doute ne vous précipitez pas aux
urgences contacté par des choses à faire
effectivement c'est le contact et le
salut c'est à dire de faire le 15
qui sera à même de répondre à leurs
questions et de les orienter si besoin
est vert par service référent en cas de
nécessité
à partir d'un interrogatoire
téléphonique une organisation identique
à tous les chu de france